[موسيقى]
هجمات صاروخيه مفاجئه من لبنان على
اسرائيل والاخيره ترد بضربات مدفعيه
وتتوعد بالمزيد اتفاقم السعودي ايراني
لاعاده فتح السفارات والقنصليات وملف
التلاعب بالانتخابات يعود الى لائحه
اتهامات ترامب هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها
لكم من قناه العربيه فاه
لا بكم
تطور خطير شهدته الحدود اللبنانيه
الاسرائيليه التصعيد بدا باطلاق نحو 30
صاروخا من الاراضي اللبنانيه نحو اسرائيل
معظم تلك الصواريخ وفقا لما افاد به مراسل
العربيه كانت من طرازي كاتيوشا واغراض
مضيفا الاسرائيلي اعلن اسقاط 25 منها عبر
منظومه القبه الحديديه فيما سقطت خمسه
بمناطق عده تسببت باصابه اسرائيليين اثنين
فردنا على ذلك قصفت اسرائيل اطراف بلدتي
لقليل والمعليه في قضاء صور جنوبي لبنان
بالمدفعيه الثقيله وهي المنطقه التي اطلقت
منها الصواريخ
وفي وقت نفد تميليش حزب الله علاقتها
باطلاق الصواريخ على اسرائيل قالت تل ابيب
ان التقييمات الامنيه توصلت الى وقوف
فصائل الفلسطينيه خلف الامر واضفت ان
انطلاق هكذا هجمات من الاراضي اللبنانيه
لن يتم الا بعلم حزب الله مجهده وزير
الخارجيه الاسرائيلي برد حازم قائلا ان
بلاده ستتخذ جميع الاجراءات لحمايه امنها
اما على الجانب الاخر من الحدود
فسيرت قوات الطوارئ الدوليه العامله في
لبنان دوريات مكثفه في المناطق الحدوديه
كما تم رصد تحليق مكثف لطائرات استطلاع
اسرائيليه باجواء جنوب لبنان
يبدو ان الالتهامات الموجهه للرئيس
الامريكي السابق دون الترامب لن تقتصر على
ملف العلاقات الغراميه فحسب مسؤولون بمجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي كشفوا خلال شهادتهم
لدى هيئه المحلفين بنيويورك حاول قلب
خسارته في انتخابات عام 2020 الى فوز من
خلال سعيه لمصادره الات التصويت
الالكترونيه انذاك حيث اتهمت شامبو وقتها
الديمقراطيين بتزوير نتائج الانتخابات
التي مهدت لفوزي جو بايدن برئاسه
اخيرا وبعد انتظار طال لعده اشهر عقب وفاه
الملكه اليزابيث ستحصل كامله باركر على
لقب الملكه مباشره بعد حفل تتويج زوجها
الملك تشارلز الثالث في السادس من مايو
المقبل الاعلان جاء بعد الكشف عن تصميمي
بطاقات الدعوه التي لقبت فيها كاميلا
بالملكه فيما بررر احد المسؤولين في قصر
باكينغهام تاخر اطلاق اللقب على الملكه
بانه كان تجنبا لبعض الارتباك بشان الملكه
اليزابيث الثانيه مضيفا ان حفل التفويج هو
الوقت المناسب لبدء استخدام لقب الملكه
رسمي
[موسيقى]